today i want to talk to you about three
different ways leaders create a
following
i'm patrick may the host of
valuetainment weekly one of my favorite
subjects to study is leadership because
you can learn so much from different
people in different industries and
spaces
on how they led their following or their
leaders and
whether it's parenting and how you raise
your kids or how a coach leads his team
how a general leads his army
how a president leads his nation how a
pastor
leads this congregation you will
generally find three different
energies that create that following i'm
gonna start off from the lowest go to
the highest lowest level
is fear-based leadership fear-based
leadership is
when a leader is all about pulling rank
it's about ego you better do this or
else it's a lot of threats it's a lot of
dictator style
uh leadership where you know the whole
purpose the premise behind fear-based
leadership is
it's all about me gaining power
and it's constantly power power power
power
power so it works on good times but the
moment you have a
couple losses or bad things happen you
lose a following examples of fear-based
leadership would be
capone was a fear-based leadership right
you think about hitler you think about
napoleon
there are examples of that but that's a
lot of fear-based leadership the second
level is
respect where it's all about you
respecting me because i have a degree
you don't know what school i went to i'm
so educated i'm so smart
you don't know what family i come from
i'm extremely competent
i'm extremely intelligent you got to
respect what i'm telling you i know what
i'm talking about
so where fear it's all about gaining
power respect it's all about gain
you know letting you know how great they
are hey
i am great at what i do it's about you
better respect
me uh it's a boss employee relationship
constantly
when it comes to respect respect would
be something like as an athlete kobe
bryant is about respect he wants you to
respect him
he doesn't care to have a relationship
with you because when he goes that's
it that's what he wants to do so that's
why when they say a lot of people don't
want to play with them
it's about respect from eisenhower
respect carter
could have been some respect because he
wanted respect because i'm smart i was
military what i did even lucky luciano
who was the leader of capone he led the
five families he was not a fear-based
person
he became respect because he brought the
five families together the italian mafia
that's about
respect so for them like i said it's
about how great they are the highest
level is
leading with love and love is not
necessarily about hugging everybody and
telling them how great they are giving
everybody a kiss and
constantly holding hands and singing
kumbaya that's not what i'm talking
about
love the element of love leading with
love
it's about trust loyalty adoration
personal relationship personal
relationship friendship
it's about unity it's about being
together
it's about an obsession to the cause so
an example of love would be
you know where fear is about how
powerful they are how great they are
love is about
how they can elevate their following
their leaders how can i get you to be
better and they're obsessed to the
bigger picture
the bigger mission the crusade and what
they're up to
that's where the love-based leadership
comes examples could be jordan jordan
had to learn he went from respect
to love because he had relationships
with horus grant with b.j armstrong pip
and ku coach rodman
he loved on them they had relay they
would go out and have dinner together
relationships together and it grew into
what it was washington
is another level that alexander loved
his following his generals
marcus aurelius falls in a category of
love love style of leadership
you know whether it's good bad tough
times it doesn't matter they stick
together
because they're some of the greatest
qualities are made up of love
so as you're listening to this fear
respect and love
one of the things you can take inventory
of yourself is which of these
three do you lead with the most yourself
you know
many times i myself anybody we sit down
and say you know in this situation i led
with fear
in this situation i led with respect
what can you
do to lead more with love to create the
kind of an environment
that's everlasting not three years only
good times not five years
not ten years but till the very end
you're leading with love
it's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel
and comment on the bottom thanks for
watching